[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and is it just me or did henry's
expression at the end of the episode
sum up everyone's thoughts on that
cliffhanger obviously we have a lot to
talk about and throughout this video
we're going to be going over everything
you need to know about the latest
episode of the undoing
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check out
the entry then i highly recommend that
you turn off now
also make sure you subscribe to the
channel as we will be covering the
finale next week
and you definitely don't want to miss it
without the way thank you for clicking
this
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
last week ended on the cliffhanger that
jonathan knew who the killer was
and we thought he might be throwing
grace under the bus when we first see
the couple
he's asking her what she was doing
beside illness that night
however she's never made a suspect it's
actually eleanor's husband fernando who
gets thrust into the spotlight
and jonathan is initially uneasy over
doing this
this suggests to me that he was thinking
grace could have done it
and could have been questioning her in
order to find out whether she blacked
out or not
anyway episode 5 picks up in the wake of
the gone girl-esque tv interview
in which jonathan admitted to loving
eleanor we catch henry watching over
this
and as jonathan says he knows who
carried out the crime the boy's face
stares back at his
suggesting that henry was indeed the one
who did it
now we do learn throughout the century
that henry did originally cover for his
father
and that he was suspicious of his dad
and guessed that something was going on
with him and eleanor
it is possible that he could have
followed the pair after the party
and then killed her in order to stop the
failure of his parents marriage
jonathan's dna was found at the scene of
the crime but because they are father
and son
henry ii would share this blood and thus
it could indeed be him
the show has very much carried a similar
feeling to defending jacob
which is definitely a series that you
should check out if you're enjoying this
anyway henry has the motive new of the
affair
and the murder weapon is also in his
violent case
however i do think that this is a red
herring and it could be that henry did
indeed discover what had happened
and he covered for his dad by hiding the
hammer the reason he held off on telling
his mother about spotting eleanor
is because he says that he felt like his
father trusted him
and in my opinion this extends beyond
the affair
at the restaurant scene henry very much
tries to repair the relationship
and also win his mother back around to
his father
because he wants a family more than
anything however in dramatic terms
i think that the henry reveal has been
dropped at the end of episode five
so that when the real reveal of the
killer comes next week
it's gonna be a big shock grace is
actually so
in love and blinded by her husband that
she may even suspect henry did it at
this point and i don't think
that she can really trust anyone it is
possible that henry followed his father
caught him killing eleanor and then
agreed to help him cover things up and
hid the weapon
so that the prosecution had less
evidence the murder weapon being missing
is a big thing that comes up as
something that will help jonathan when
things go to court
and i guess the police didn't do a very
good job of searching the property
because
that would have definitely been one of
the places i looked anyway
go to court things do and grace must
play that she loves jonathan
in order to manipulate the jury into
seeing their relationship in a certain
light
so that the murder is shifted away from
him the defense really started to put
the blame on fernando
and franklin really struggles with this
and the episode itself dramatically is
very much about an image versus the
truth
sure you can convince people fernando
killed his wife
but is it the truth sure jonathan might
be innocent
and seem that way but can we trust him
sure tubing looks like he's working
again but is he actually doing this
is lubin with tube in a thing and is is
should i stop talking about this now yes
definitely anyway back to the episode
sure the police said they investigated
everyone and if they didn't
does that mean they're people we can
trust it's questions like these that
rise throughout the entry and no that's
not a tuban pun and i think this show
has done a fantastic job of keeping us
guessing about who is really behind the
crime
now i am still of the mind that it is
indeed jonathan
and so far the episodes have thrown us
teasers and cliffhangers to suggest that
it is of the characters like his son and
wife
however this episode we learn the truth
about his dark past namely that he was
responsible for his sister's death
if you read the book then you'll know
this was a very important reveal
and it explained why jonathan had stayed
so distant from his family
there are some minor changes such as it
being his brother aaron and the source
material
but on the whole it's very much in line
with the book's plot
now with this comes the fact that
jonathan has lied about the event to
pretty much
everyone outside of his immediate family
he's covered things up
and fled from it much like how he fled
after elena was killed
there's a pattern that re-emerges here
and it's extremely suspicious that
two young vulnerable females in his life
that he apparently cared for
both ended up dead this is why i believe
that they changed it from his brother in
the book to his sister in the show
as were meant to be mentally joining the
dots to see how history has repeated
itself
jonathan apparently showed absolutely no
remorse over this
and a trauma such as losing your child's
sibling renders some people psychotic
the other women in his life that were
part of these two major events such as
his wife and mother
they have a view of him where they
believe they know what happened
deep down but their image of jonathan
has warped this
now jonathan's mother i think is well
aware of what happened
and likely thinks that he killed both
his sister and eleanor
however grace isn't there yet and as the
episode progresses
jonathan wins windsor background at one
point in the episode she returns to the
house
and the pair spend the night together
this shows that
even though he's admitted to an affair
that he loved another woman
and likely killed her grace wants to
remain in the stream world
her father did state that she fell for
jonathan simply because she told him
what the perfect man for her was
and that he simply altered himself to be
this way if the character is a master
manipulator
then this would be well within his
wheelhouse and even his lawyer accused
him of being able to mesmerize people
which grace is a victim of if our
theories are correct now a lot of you on
the last video
dropped comments about how you think
that the second woman he had an affair
with
might actually be sylvia upon reading
these i had a big
aha moment and i definitely agree that
it's the case
however i think it might actually extend
beyond this
and that there could be more than one
woman this would make things
more awkward than the restaurant scene
you know the one where where the waiter
was cleaning the table
a miss restaurant to do but you know
there are a lot of hints here
anyway jonathan seems happy for fernando
to take the fall
which like the situation with his sister
shows he has little remorse over the
loss of someone's life
now whilst i do think that it is him i
also believe that he could get away with
the crime
as his lawyer has done an incredible job
of casting doubt over his guilt
she brings up the fact that he is the
father of eleanor's child
and also makes fernando violently lash
out in court
after asking about his wife's
psychiatric problems
as we know she was obsessed with grace i
think these mental issues
could swing things in his favor it will
however come down to grace in the finale
and she will have to decide whether to
bring the murder weapon to light and
tear her family apart
or continue living in this untrue
reality in which she believes everything
is perfect
i really think that it's gonna cause a
lot of conflict and the character will
have to decide to put the life she's
loved to decide
in order to do the right thing it's all
gonna kick off
and unfortunately my breakdown of the
finale will come a bit late next week
hbo and sky atlantic have been sending
me the episode
slightly earlier so i could prepare my
videos but they want everyone to keep
tight lipped on the last episode
so i'll be watching at the same time as
you guys probably still be up on the
monday
but yeah don't call the police if i'm a
couple of minutes late anyway that
concludes the episode
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it as well as what your
theories are
if you enjoy this video then please drop
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of last week's entry which
will be linked at the end
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of november so make sure you
get involved
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the joy button below
you can also come chat is on the discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you be the best i've been paul i'll see
you next time take care
peace
[Music]
oh